Russian forces are
making gradual
gains as they try
to encircle Ukrainian fighters in Bakhmut
President Zelensky is calling it, quote,
one of the toughest battles yet
despite a Russian blitz,
Ukrainian forces say
that they are still holding on
to a key highway
in the fiercely contested city.
Just a short time ago.
The defense
secretary, Lloyd Austin,
said it would not be a strategic setback
if Ukrainians decide to reposition
in some areas to the West of Bakhmut.
The town's deputy mayor
telling CNN
there are about 4500
Ukrainian residents still in the city
and in harm's way.
So let's bring in now retired U.S.
Army Major General Mike Lyons.
Good morning to you.
Let's focus on Bakhmut here.
So the secretary is saying
that it would not be
a strategic setback for Ukraine
if they lose this city.
Is that true?
And what does this the significance of?
Yeah, I think it is true.
I think the bottom line is both sides
are using this battle
to grind the other side down.
And Ukraine's winning in that regard.
They're about a seven to one ratio
seven to one Russias down
for one Ukraine.
However, they still don't have enough
manpower there.
Here's really
what's happening on the ground right now.
The Russians.
From what we can tell,
are using a kind of envelopment
to try to envelop the city here,
a very kind of wide circle here.
Why hasn't Russia taken it directly?
And I'll tell you why.
There's a river.
Ukraine has used an incredible
amount of obstacles
in order to protect the city.
There's a river that goes here that
the Russians can't navigate at all.
And so we can tell
what either side is doing by
how they drop bridges across rivers.
So, for example,
the Ukraine military
just dropped that river,
which tells me now
they're retreating back
into the town of Buck Mode
and eventually taking this
this is the 504
the 504 road back to even, let's say.
But the Russians now,
they drop a bridge here and come over.
So they're trying to prevent
the Ukrainians
from from escaping from this route
there as well.
So we're seeing now
actually what both sides are going to do
and likely where Ukraine will be able
to evade Russian forces
to leave the city.
So considering what you just said
and how they're surrounded.
How much longer do you think
Ukrainian forces can hold on?
So so they've got to decide
how much more casualties
they really want to take.
And both sides
have been grinding each other down.
And here at this point,
I think they're going to do this
for the next 24 to 48 hours.
And there's no
there's no loss in that for them.
You know,
they'd when the enemy is strong
or at this point,
I think that's really what
with the decision that they're making.
Can we talk about the volunteer group
because they have been spearheading
this push for a path.
Can you explain
to us their involvement here?
They're mercenaries about 50,000 troops
we know in the dumbass region.
10,000 regular contractors about 40,000.
Penal colony prisoners
people that have
made this choice
to come join the battle here
because as opposed to sitting
in a Russian penal colony,
they're unbounded by the laws of land
and warfare.
Russia uses them
for plausible deniability.
They were first deployed back in 20 2014
and Crimea as the little green men.
They're not really warriors.
Their head for Goshen
is a former caterer of Vladimir Putin.
But here's the deal
we now see that he's
now complaining about the situation
and he says
they're not getting enough ammo.
So he's now sensing a loss.
He's sensing
that they're not
going to be able to hold it.
And really
what they've done to the city
the cities and rebels
and center
4500 left from what was 80,000 civilians.
There's nothing
that if they've really not gained
any victory.
They're not bound by
sort of traditional rules.
Is this why they're involved
instead of Russian troops?
They can't seem to muster enough
Russian troops
that want to do this fight.
This is a suicide mission.
Again,
these frontal assaults here on
locations in trench warfare
with all the different obstacles.
The Russian soldiers are smart.
They recognize they're not going to
they're not going to
survive those battles.
Thank you. Peter.
Michael, good to see you.
Thank you.
Let's go straight
to CNN's
most about live for us in Kyiv right now.
Hello to you, Melissa.
The fight has been going on
for more than seven months.
Now, wondering
if Ukraine will be able to turn it around
and keep the city
I think their aim, Don, is at this point
just to hold it for as long as they can.
And this is their tried
and tested strategy.
We've seen it in other towns
in this war so far,
although none at the heart of a battle
this long yet
to try and hold on
for as long as they can,
whatever the cost to them
insofar as it wears down
the Russian ability
to continue waging this war
and whatever the cost
Ukrainian forces
giving all their can to defend Bakhmut
or what's left of it.
After the longest battle of the war,
one of the oldest cities in the Donbass
lies in ruins.
There were no orders,
no decisions were made
regarding withdrawal from Bakhmut.
There have been no tactical changes.
We are holding the defense
abandoned by more than
90% of
its population
over the course of the seven month siege.
Only those who couldn't leave before
are left.
The intense fighting
means
that only five to ten people
a day can now be evacuated.
Compared to the 500 to 600 a day
when the evacuation
started at the end of February,
according to the city's deputy mayor,
the Russians throwing all they have at
the city, says the deputy mayor.
Heavy artillery, mortar fire, airstrikes
and a substantial commitment
of ground forces,
both regular soldiers
and volunteer mercenaries.
But Russian advances have come at huge
cost.
Wave after
wave of
Russian soldiers
have been sent to their deaths.
And Ukraine has accused Russia
of exaggerating its gains,
claiming they still control one of the
major highways into Bermuda.
A lifeline for Ukrainian defenders.
With one Ukrainian commander
tweeting that there are many ways still
to get into the city.
Analysts have questioned
the strategic importance of Bermuda.
But that has not stopped
Moscow's intense campaign
to capture the city.
Nor Ukraine's existential fight
to keep it.
The unceasing barrage of artillery fire
hasn't just killed or forced out
most of the city's civilians.
It's taken a huge toll
on Ukrainian soldiers, too.
As the battle turns
to close quarters, street fighting
But Ukraine continues
its fierce fight for victory.
Even as Russian forces
continue to close in
on a city
that's already a byword
for Ukrainian resilience,
On the battlefield
what's most remarkable,
maybe, Dawn,
is that more than 100 years
after the end of World War One,
just how much this looks like
some of the early battles of that war.
Trench warfare,
heavy artillery
and wave after
wave of inexperienced soldiers
on both sides
being sent to their certain death.
And it's happening in Europe again.